let's show some video of that because
this is really an extraordinary moment
the president
leaves the country he is thousands and
thousands of miles away on the other
side of the earth and then who shows up
at the white house to meet with his wife
and the pres the vice president
how you feeling
yesterday we're on hand exclusively as
governor gavin newsom enters the west
wing of the white house amid speculation
about his political future during this
trip newsom is meeting with vice
president kamala harris white house
chief of staff ron klain and first lady
dr jill biden what is the message that
you're trying to convey to
jill biden today to vice president to
leaders on the hill have your back have
your back
he is such a slimy
smarmy
inauthentic
soulless i really believe he is soulless
i do not think he has a human soul he
has wrecked originally he wrecked san
francisco as the mayor then he wrecked
california as the governor but just in
terms of the optics alone they knew what
they were doing dr jill who clearly has
not examined joe she knew exactly what
she was doing by having that guy show up
to the white house kamala knew exactly
what they were doing joe's not not here
let's get this guy in i mean that's the
plan right kurt like how are they going
to do this thing they're going to get
him to step down she'll jump in as as
president for a little bit they'll get
him as vp nancy will be upset because
she's not and then they'll get kamala to
step down and then he jumps in at 24
like what are they doing here oh well
look i i i think that's a good
explanation for him going to washington
and playing doctor with jill
[Laughter]
i mean he he is a smarmy weasel but i i
just
i i find it
uh amusing that blue america
the little ruling class thinks that the
rest of america the ones that actually
vote
are going to want to turn their their
state into another california okay it
used to be you know california used to
be the land of swing palm trees and
opportunity i got there with uh when uh
uh governor reagan was in charge and i i
was able to you know make all my dreams
come true if you want to use a hat
cliche but it's it's a fact and now it's
about uh hobos dropping their used
dinner on the sidewalk and having to
play hopscotch avoid being impaled by
hypodermic needles uh i i
you know get the the one of the other
problems for gavin newsom besides the
fact that he's got the albatross that is
having turned managed to turn a great
state like california into a hellhole
is he's really going to have to trash
joe by
hard
to to differentiate himself and i think
that's going to alienate some of the
democrats i like the democrats are in a
bad place and the republicans are very
in a very good one which is why you see
uh president trump is very eager to get
back in the race i think he will i wrote
a uh i wrote a piece the case for donald
trump and the case against donald trump
and town hall and uh the president sent
me a nice note on a printout of the case
against donald trump that said you're
gonna be very happy with what i do i
will not let you down okay all right oh
yeah i'm running but then we've also got
uh ron desantis who is outstanding
um
i i i'm looking forward to a powerful
republican primary where we really
figure out who the best guy is and the
uh voters of the republican party uh
decide who to go with because client 24
is a huge opportunity i think i think
our win is uh
very very likely unless we do some
insane like you know nominate girl jeb
uh nikki haley
i happen to like nikki but i i know a
certain amount of the bass doesn't dig
her uh but chad all right so let's i
think we're all in agreement on newsom
and you know this i don't know if you
saw the ad where he's you know going
after florida and going after desantis
and it's like literally every word is a
lie and that he dares even say the word
freedom is so extraordinary but let's
just back up to what kurt said there the
trump desantis thing that's really the
thing that now is on everyone's mind you
know having gotten to know governor
desantis a little bit i don't know that
he's going to run for president but i
know he loves florida this guy lives and
breathes this state
do you have a preference and do you
think there's one that that works better
than the other or do you think they can
have a meeting a closed-door meeting and
work this thing out
if it's
look i don't i don't know if donald
trump's ego allows that to happen i i
would hope so that maybe there is some
you know tinge of humility left inside
there i don't know if it's ever existed
uh i i would hope so you know i think
that trump is sitting in a legacy
position where he really could be a god
maker uh in many ways to be the neck
that turns the head and pull a lot of
you know pull a lot of
um people into play that could be major
game changers without the rhetoric and
the necessary attacks by the the media
towards a donald trump if he was the
actual guy in charge now i'll take trump
10 000 times over this [ __ ]
nightmare we're living right now
uh but i do hold out hopes that a guy
like ron desantis who who not only has
had good policy and good convictions who
loves his state he loves his job
but a guy who has been able to pull that
separation further apart between between
the leftist and right-wing ideologies
and show some real common sense and i
think right now it's not about political
parties look i say it all the time i
don't care if you have an r or a d by
your name if you're a big government
person you're garbage you're you're
human waste though you're the enemy of
the american people and i don't see ron
desantis as being that
and i would love to i would love to see
how that plays out on the national level
foreign